la première fois qu'on ses juges et elle
aimerait vous raconter une histoire
belge et tu m'avais raconter une
histoire assez drôle ni c'est pourquoi
il faut être 5 en belgique pour changer
une ampoule
c'est le championnat qui devait dans
tout le pays américains qui comme
l'appelle c'est comme un conte est une
autre histoire belgique deux belges et
gaston herman il alors tous les deux en
train de faire un test pour être
embauché dans une firme beige et ils ont
fait tout l'été ils sont excellents tous
les deux et pour n'est plus voilà le
contremaître il arrive pas à la vie pas
les départager
donc ils vivront pas je suis obligé de
vous poser une question subsidiaire ont
très bien alors d'abord à bout portant
alors qu'est-ce qui sommet au pied c'est
en cuir et ça sert à marcher un peu près
d'accord
une question je vous plaît est ce que ce
sera des marchés oui oui ça des races et
des chaussures alors bravo lancé des
chaussures mes traits parfaits allez
maintenant à vous monsieur alors fait
quoi
il ya plein de poils partout et qui fait
miaou et qui boit du lait je peux poser
une question à monsieur herman monsieur
carton dans une question qu'on a posé
une question c'est est-ce que ça a
dépassé
non monsieur herman ça m'apprendra c'est
enfin un côté répétitif des mocassins